Fenrir the most infamous of many wolves
in Norse mythology son of Loki and
father to buff skull and hearty Fenrir
possessed a great strength and what
seemed to be limitless growth the gods
fear for finn rey was so great that they
raised him themselves within the
stronghold of Asgard in order to keep
him under control only till the god of
war and justice dared to approach Fenrir
in order to feed him Henry has growth
alarm the gods and soon they decided he
staying as God could not be permanent
they knew if they allowed him to roam
free
Fenrir would cause untold devastation
across the nine worlds so they attempted
to bind him in Chains
the gods knew that Fenrir would never
willingly consent to be in put in Chains
they convinced Fenrir that the chains
were a test of strength
clapping and cheering every time he
broke free of a new chain fernery
continued to accept the challenges as he
wished to show the gods his strength and
earn their respect the gods soon
realized that no chain they could craft
could hold Fenrir they would seek aid
from the Dwarven realm of sparta lion
the dwarves been the most skilled
craftsmen in all of the nine worlds were
able to form a chain whose strength
could not be equalled when the gods
presented Fenrir with this new light and
supple chain venery suspected trickery
it was at this point when Fenner again
to realize how the gods saw him as an
enemy they would kill given the chance
he refused to be bound unless one of the
gods placed their hand in his jaws as a
show of good faith
none of the gods agreed to do so knowing
that they would lose their hand
however taya was brave and he was
willing to sacrifice his hand for the
people of the nine worlds he agreed to
fenner his demands and placed his hand
in his jaws once FINRA discovered he
could not escape the Dwarven chains he
indeed chomped down and swallowed his
hand
now that Fenrir was contained he was
taken to a desolate place and tied to a
giant boulder with a sword placed in
between his jaws keeping them open
Fenrir had grown so big that when he
held the drool from his mouth formed the
lake during the Ragnarok Fenrir broke
free and ran throughout the world with
his lower jaw against the ground upper
jaw in the sky Fenrir devoured
everything in his path
before being killed by one of Odin's
sons Fenrir did manage to achieve the
revenge he craved by killing and
devouring Odin it is said that femoris
two sons skull and hearty followed in
their father's footsteps with one
swallowing the Sun and the other the
moon they destroyed the stars and all
essence of time the story of Henry is an
intriguing one I personally don't
believe that fenway was evil he only
desired to be accepted by his fellow
gods after years of being treated like a
beast he became the monster that
everybody thought he was if you've
enjoyed this video then please go ahead
and leave it a like consider subscribing
if folklore and mythology is something
that interests you if you have anything
you'd like to discuss or have any ideas
for future videos then please go ahead
and let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained